if I feel that I could be sudden when I
would say the things I want to say - it
was supposed to be cable okay sorry that
my theaters been going through some
pretty rough times lately so what do I
do
quit no my next show is gonna be
drumroll please a singing competition
you think your neighbor the the grocery
store manager that that chicken right
there real talent from real life mermen
would you please tell them what a good
singer I am oh yeah you were great honey
by the way the bathroom sink is blocked
again I'm here win that prize it's mine
everyone in the city gets a shot at
being a star on my stage come my lady
you're my butterfly
like the wheel rock oh my gosh look at
her butt yeah
you okay oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you people say you're Humpty
you're really funny looking the show is
not gonna save your theater maybe it's
time to just move on come on you know
how much this means to us
you can't just sing it you got two shows
a file desire the fire went out a long
time ago you are not gonna believe what
I did today I am lost I am bad I just
don't want to be in the gang I want to
be a singer
lawyered up with a son like you get you
out nine wait okay the money I promised
I could really use some extra piano
lessons yes that was very bad a defining
moment in all of our lives we're going
to be spicy no yeah
don't let fear stop you from doing the
thing you love you know what's great
about hitting rock bottom there's only
one way left to go and that's
see
DiBiase
in Aisle 6 that was awesome
Iko by Rory by Mickey by Mel by Nelson
by Hannah by tasks by by Casper